no doubt a big weekend ahead for the
lake but with dropping water levels a
popular boat launch ramp
is now closed madison kimbrough joining
us live right near the marina to fully
explain madison
yeah with the decreasing water levels
here at lake mead boaters
are concerned as you can see behind me
tons of boats and people out and about
and now with the most popular ramp
closed at boulder harbor their concern
is that the other ramps will just get
too over populated to use
according to late meat officials the
channel depth is about two and a half
feet deep
and that's just too low to provide safe
lake access at boulder harbor
the lake's level has dropped
significantly in the last 20 years
and it's expected to hit a new record
low in the next coming weeks
making it very hard for boaters to drive
around with the concern of rocks popping
out from under the water and sand bars
boaters explain how it's been out on the
water and how they feel about this
recent closure
through that channel yeah it's just
super low narrow
so it's gotta be yeah super mindful we
slowed down
just kind of kept an eye we got to the
front bow and just kind of looked at the
front and
yeah this went super slow drive all the
way out here you know weighs the gas i
see it closed and then have to go
somewhere else yeah
it's like the more they shut it down
then the more traffic it is longer for
you to launch a boat longer to get out
currently lake mead is below 1072
feet and the last time it was above sea
level was back in 2000.
as for ramps that are currently open on
lake mead hemingway harbor and
caulville bay are currently open for
boat access so you can look out for that
reporting live from lake mead madison
kimbrough 8 news now
madison thanks the